hey mitchell what's up brother so my
fiance is an icu nurse and uh she's been
dealing with the worst side of the
pandemic here
yeah she loves her job yeah she loves
her job but i can see it's taking a toll
on her spirit and it's just
you know emotionally draining we talk
every day when she comes
home when she comes home from work but
you know aside from listening
what else can i be doing to support her
emotionally and just spiritually
man dude i'm i'm so grateful for you
mitchell
thank you for your heart and for being
one of those guys that
wants to love your wife the best way you
know how
so when she comes home give everybody a
penis a picture of what life is like
when she gets home
she walks through the door then what
sure um i would say
you know it's every other day it's a
pretty sad day she'll lose a patient or
two
um and it's when they lose covet
patients in the icu
you know families don't get to go say
bye she has to be the one
yeah hold the ipad and hold that
patient's hand
um when they leave this earth so she
carries that
you know she carries that burden um i
can see that on her shoulders
and i feel a little helpless because
i can't relieve that for her yeah
enough hey nothing's worse than
watching somebody you love hurt and
you can't be the one that heals that
right yep
it hurts it's hard man um and
you alluded to it i just i'll go one
step further
and i know this is a little bit graphic
but when somebody gets to a place where
their end of their time has come and
they're they're being propped up by
machines
and the doctor says it's time it's the
nurse
that reaches down and turns the machines
off that pulls the proverbial plug that
pulls the tubes out that actually
pulls the lifeline out of somebody's
vein
and if you if if and i know you know
this mitchell because you know this
acutely but
for those of you who don't know nurses
carry that around with them
i'm the one the doctor made the
declaration
but i'm the one that turned the switch
i'm the one that pulled that
too and you want to talk about carrying
some weight
right it is a weight that very very few
people will ever
ever i'll never understand that right
that's a weight so
she comes home and she talks to you tell
me how those conversations go how do
they
paint us a picture of it is it in your
bedroom is it in the living room y'all
have kids tell me tell me what that
looks like
yeah we don't have kids um we're
actually about to so it's not my wife
yet but we're about to be married in
about a month here
okay um you know oh yeah okay yeah
yeah um it's sometimes on the couch um
if it's a very heavy day um
it's one of those where you know we sit
down across the table from each other
and
we'll talk about it and talk about it
face to face
um those are the heaviest days because
you know really all my attention needs
to be in that and
you know just listening to her there are
you a therapist man
i'm not well what do you do for a living
um i'm in customer success i work in you
know
tech if you will so i mean i i hope i i
listen for a living
i was gonna say man she won the lottery
with you brother
i wish i had had you as a friend talking
about knowing experts i wish i had known
you when i first got married so
long ago cause you would have told me
stop talking stop talking
and just listen right you're a great
friend to have so
here's a couple of things you can do
number one
you were already there knowing i can't
fix this
most spouses want to fix it
and what that does number one is it
turns their partner into a machine
which they're not right it turns them
into something that is quote unquote
broken
which she's not but she does need to
process sadness
she does need to process that isolating
feeling you get when you
turn a switch and somebody's life ends
even if it's the right humane thing
or when you stop a ventilator or fill in
the blank
man that is lonely in a world that no
one can understand that kind of
loneliness right you can't
solve that but she's not broken right
she's processing this and
feeling this and experiencing this so
here's a couple of things you can do
number one um i'm you don't do this and
so i'm speaking this into existence for
other folks who are listening
ask somebody how you can best love them
don't try to love them the best way you
know how
often folks try to love each other with
the only tools they have right which is
maybe
physical touch maybe buying a bunch of
gifts maybe giving a bunch of advice
and if that's not how somebody else
feels loved it ends up crushing
them right because they then try to have
to also have the burden of making you
feel good about
the gift that they don't want or that's
burning them but they know you're doing
it with a good spirit right
so just ask the question when she's
sitting across the table from you
reach your hands out when she touch when
she's talking to you
if you can if she will is able to touch
you when she does that there's a
processing
that happens when you have physical
touch and you're talking to somebody
that makes it very visceral very real
if she'll reach across that table and
hold your hand while she's talking to
you it'd be awesome
and when she gets done ask her those
words out loud
how can i best love you right now just
ask her hey how can i best love you
right now right
the second thing is what are things that
wear her out
and i'm taking emily nagaski's language
what are some of her offs
not just you know in the bedroom right
but what are some offs things that she
hates doing
and it could be filling the car up with
gas for years my wife hated getting gas
and so it was just a big deal
on sunday nights i just go fill her car
right things like that what are
what are things that drive her bananas
about the world that you could take from
her and lighten her load
i mean the easy one for us is laundry
that
that never goes away yeah man
it's a burden for us you know we both we
do work uh
full time and you know at the end of the
week it'll just be a mountain and we're
like where did that even come from
yes and it grows right that's how we
spend our weekend
you know just doing chores because we're
working through the week um
so yeah laundry and dishes so i would
say the normal household you know
she's exhausted when she comes home so
that's not something
we want to do do you have a laundry like
a washer dryer inside your
place we do okay so
this is something i started as part of
my morning routine a few weeks ago i'm
just giving it a shot and it has been
it's one of those moments things has
pushed me into like a shame cycle
because of how easy it is
and that is in the morning when i wake
up i just go switch one load of laundry
i'm trying to squeeze in one thing of
service a day just one
right and it's best in the morning
before my kids are awake
and i can just move one thing from the
washer to the dryer and the dryer out
and i fold it and i can set it there and
go hang it up it takes
five minutes max five minutes but
usually three
and then it's over and then on saturday
we don't get this insane pile that grows
up
does that make sense so there's these
little ways to begin to chip away at
that
in a problem-solving way but think
through those things i know you're tired
too
but what are those things you can give
to her in this season of chaos
that's going to be a gift to your entire
family unit you're holding her arms up
in the desert right now when she's
exhausted and there will come a season
in your relationship when she'll hold
yours up right
but right now this is that moment for
y'all what find some things that just
are a burden to her
and see if you can take those from her
you're adding onto your plate you don't
have any space and i get that
but she's in a season of crisis and so
i'm asking you to step into those
moments right
so the third thing is you said you'll
have a debrief time
here's something that may not work for
every couple this is just an idea
if you guys have a gratitude journal
where
here but it's going to be a unique one i
want you to go buy a journal and buy
something fancy pants
and set it in a place where she can see
it right
whether that's on on the bed at night
at a place where she sits down and reads
but i want you to write three or four
things that start with i'm grateful for
her and write it out right and it could
be the same thing sometimes
leave it in a place where she's going to
see it and ask her
if she will take a moment or two a day
to write out some things she experienced
that day
and what i want her to begin to do is
associate your
continued gratitude for her she's not a
burden to you
she is the joy of your life you're about
to commit to spend the rest of your life
with her forever and ever i'm in
and i want to give her a space to begin
to write some of this stuff out and get
it out of her head
right and so it's a it's a multi-tier
task she may say i'm not writing
anything but i'll
i'll read your gratitude journal she may
take your gratitude and throw it on the
floor like i'm not reading that right
now
you keep doing it keep doing it because
here's why after
two months of doing laundry and doing
all the stuff in the dishes all by
yourself you're gonna start getting
resentful and exhausted too because
you're working a full-time job right
you're not doing this together anymore
you just picked up all the slack
i want you to be reminding yourself i'm
grateful for her man i am grateful for
her
and i want her to see the daily
decisions you're making to love her
and over time she's going to love
herself bonus if she'll write it down
okay
now here's the last thing i want you all
to do every morning before you guys
leave for work
i want you to hold your hands and look
her in the eye and say i love you
and what does your picture of today look
like
what do you got on your plate not hey
how can i serve you because now she's
got to come up with a bunch of reasons
why she's
what are what does your picture look
like for today
just giving an architecture providing
architecture for the day for the both of
you
is freeing right and then it allows her
to go in and do the hard hard work that
she's got to do
and then she can circle out come home be
fully herself sit at that table and look
at the guy she loves and just says
and say well this happened today and you
can hold their hands looking in the eye
and say
i hate that for you i'm so so sorry i'm
so so sorry how can i love you right now
and then in the morning oh my gosh
what's the picture of today going to
look like
what's it going gonna look like today
i'm gonna do one i'm gonna sneak one i'm
gonna sneak two
little acts of service throughout the
day so that on saturday or sunday
our days can be going for walks can be
going outside
she can take some quiet time she can
have some journaling time give her some
of that space that she desperately needs
to process this trauma that she's
experiencing right
it's a lot it's a lot it's a lot but
first and foremost mitchell thank you so
much for your heart and for your soul
so grateful for you brother so grateful